and Al jazer has gained exclusive access
to the largest city of the carabat
region after it was recaptured by aaban
from ethnic Armenians and this is what
our team witnessed in h
Candi in the main Square there are empty
streets deserted homes and shuttered
businesses more than 100,000 people
living in the region have fled to
neighboring Armenia only a small
fraction have remained that is despite
azan's assurances that they will be
integrated as equal citizens Al jaz's
Osama bin Javed has this exclusive
report from Khan
kendi you've been seeing pictures from
Khan kendi in the last few days tens of
thousands of people who had lined up the
square with all that was uh they could
carry with them people who were in their
carss were queuing up to leave outside
and and leave the city but people who
were here were waiting for buses for
their relatives for others to come and
take them with them as they did not
believe the assurances that were given
by the aarani government that they will
not be prosecuted here in the Town
Center if I go quiet you'd be able to
hear nothing there is absolutely no one
who's left here uh apart from a few
elderly uh disabled and others uh we did
see some uh Red Cross workers who were
here earlier uh who were taking people
fing them away and taking them to a
staging Point uh from where they're
going to take them into Armenia that's
what people want here let me just show
you here are some puppies uh who've been
following us around possibly looking for
food uh this is this is a uh hard to
describe feeling on when you enter a
town where you've been looking at
pictures of it uh where there was so
much activity but now uh a ghost town uh
which seems to have no soul left as
we've been uh driving through this town
we've uh looked at open shutters uh
we've left at uh We've looked at cars uh
where doors are open uh so it does feel
like this was an exodus it feels like
where people thought that they are uh
they have to leave as quick as they can
although we were hearing uh when we were
outside of Hindi uh from aarani
officials that uh they they're free to
stay they they have nothing to fear but
you have to understand the history of
the last three decades as well because
there's been so much hatred so much
violence uh there's been so much uh that
has gone on between these two sides that
it was difficult for people to imagine
uh what peace between the two sides
would look like 30 years ago when
Armenian forces came in they renamed all
of these areas with Armenian names this
used to be known as khi other places
like H and kalbar were also named with
aarani names but they were changed one
Armenian forces took control of these
areas and a self- declared State came
into place uh but now aeran have come
into uh administra administrative
control we've also been seeing
ambulances to uh give make sure that
there is some some sort of relief for
people we met the icrc we asked them and
they said that it is uh going to help
them to ensure that the people who are
left behind have uh some essential
services available the electricity as
you can see the lights are still running
the water is still running although Aid
workers tell us that they can't be sure
of who are who the people who used to
run the water supply are no longer here
and behind us uh is now the the vehicle
is left is where uh the Russian
peacekeepers were stationed because this
was was a staging Point uh where people
were gathering and leaving but this is
what a city uh without people looks like
it is scenes that we have never seen
before such a huge mass of population
got up and left leaving all that they
could leave behind with them and just
taking their memories and all they could
pack on their cars with
them Osama bin Javed reporting there
from the carabat region where a un
Mission arrived on Sunday it's the first
time the UN reaches the region in three
decades the team will assess the
humanitarian need in an area that has
been almost entirely emptied of its
population